MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.701.
So the name of this plan
is called Casimir's trick.
But what we're
actually going to do
is we're going to
evaluate or learn
how to deal with
spin information
in the calculation of
our matrix elements.
So now what is it
we're trying to do?
So the first problem
we might have
is that we have
polarized particles.
So we have here again our
example of electron muon
scattering.
And if you assume that
the electron and the muons
are polarized, you will
find as we discussed
in the previous lecture
that our matrix element is
proportional to the adjoined
vector of mu 1 times
some sort of gamma
matrix times the spinor.
And we probably
have a polarization
that is as well
included here to give
the polarization of the photon
involved at the propagating.
Good.
Now in order to now
get a number for M,
we actually have to be explicit
about the base function
of the external particles.
And you can do this-- you
can just write this down.
However, in experiments,
we are often
interested in the scattering
of unpolarized particles.
Even if you have a way
to polarize a beam,
your polarization is
not going to be perfect.
So in your
calculation, you might
want to average or
some opposite available
spins of your particle.
So how are we going to do this?
So we're trying to calculate
the spin average amplitude.
Why averaging?
We want to average
over the polarization
of the incoming
particles, again,
because we don't know what
the polarization states are.
And we want to sum of the
polarization of all final state
particles simply because
each polarization
state is a possible
outcome of the interaction.
And we have to sum over
all possible outcomes.
Good.
So how do we calculate the
spin average amplitude?
So again, we start
from our matrix element
where we have the
adjoined vectors and gamma
matrix or spinor.
If you then calculate the
square of this matrix,
we find this solution here.
Great.
And now we're just
doing a few tricks.
So first of all, we can
write our adjoined mu 1 equal
to mu [INAUDIBLE] 1, gamma 0.
And then just continue
this rewriting to refine
this part here of
he solution, which
looks a little bit
simpler where we
now the adjoined matrix instead
of the adjoined matrix given
here.
So we want to evaluate what this
adjoined u1 gamma u2 is times
adjoined u2 gamma adjoined u1.
Good.
So this was just matrix algebra
and working with gamma so far.
Now we're using this
completion relation
where I probably
haven't told you yet
what this syntax here is.
So gamma flash is
equal to gamma mu p mu.
And that's just the way to
simplify it writing down
the equation.
So if you use this
so-called Feynman's slash,
you can also rewrite that Dirac
equation in the simple form phi
del flesh minus M y equal to 0.
That's now our
direct [INAUDIBLE]..
Remember there was
a gamma mu in here.
All right, let's just
decide now again.
We have to sum over all
spin states, or the spin
states of all those particles.
Now if you start with
something over particle 2,
we can rewrite this here.
We use this equation, this
completely-filled relation,
and just really find this q
as equal to this part here.
So now we have
this equation here,
which looks a little bit
simpler, because we just
have our incoming and outgoing
spinors for particle 1 given
here.
All right, now we're looking at
this part of the equation now.
And again, we're just doing a
little bit of matrix algebra
here.
And you find that this is
equal to q u 1 mu 1, i-i,
which is just simply something
over the same indices, which
is the same as building
the trace of this matrix.
All right, so if you just
put all of us together,
you find that calculating
the sum of matrix elements,
it's similar to building
the trait of a matrix.
And then our final results
then give you [INAUDIBLE]..
All right, so summarizing this
part, we have a matrix element.
And we saw that the matrix
elements of this form's
proportional to this form.
And then when we try to
calculate the spin average
matrix element squared,
that's equal to the traits
of the particles involved
using the completion image.
There's an additional
factor of 1/2
here, which comes
from the averaging
over the initial spins.
So assuming exactly one
of u1 and u2 corresponds
to the initial particles
defined as vector 1/2,
if both initial
particles are the same,
like in a parent relation,
then vector is 1/4.
And if neither is in
the initial state,
then the factor is 1, which you
would have for fair production.
Good.
So now we simplified the
calculation of our matrix
elements, putting the
specific spin states
in there and the specific
polarization vectors to what
the calculation of
traces of matrices.
So now we can look
at what does it mean.
So this is what Casimir's
trick really is about.
So summing over spins reduces
to summing over matrices.
If you have antiparticles,
the completeness relation,
which uses two p/minus M,
and then you we go ahead.
So all you need to know now
is how to do this trace it.
So first, some general
remarks on traces.
We have to matches,
A and B. You want
to calculate the
trace of A plus B. Set
equal to the trace of
A plus the trace of B.
If you have a multiplicator
here, a vector alpha,
you can just take this out of
the calculation of the trace.
In the traces, two
matrices commutate.
The trace of A times B is equal
to the trace of B times A.
And then you can
use this in order
to show a more
complicated relationships.
Good.
We have already started playing
around with the gamma Here
are a few more identities
which might be of use when
you calculate
traces and calculate
matrix elements overall.
The first one is g mu nu
times g mu nu is equal to 4.
The anti-commutator relations
we already discussed
and have shown in one
of our recitation.
And if you have
three matrices you
can rewrite them
as minus 2 times
the matrix, which is
in the middle here.
So I'm not going through
this in much detail here,
but I encourage
you to just follow,
it's an additional exercise.
We didn't have the opportunity
yet to play with the quantum.
And then you can use
those tricks, for example.
And commutator relation
to calculate the traces.
For example, the gamma
mu, is 4 times g mu nu.
OK, so what you see
here is basically
used this anti-commutator.
Put it in here,
use this part here,
this is basically one
trade-off, 1 is 4.
So we get g mu-mu
times the trace the 1.
But 4 times 4 matrix is 4.
And so you get the trace
of gamma mu gamma mu
is equal to 4 times
g mu, and so on.
Later on, we haven't
discussed gamma 5 so much,
gamma 5 is defined as 5 times
gamma 0, gamma 1, gamma 2,
gamma 3.
We will see them and discuss
the weak interaction.
That there's a prominent
role will come up
this very special gamma matrix.
And here are just some
pieces of information
for traces for gamma 5.
The trace of gamma 5 is at 0.
The trace of gamma 5 times--
sorry-- a different
gamma matrix is zero.
And that's also true for the
product of additional gamma
matrix that you can
find when you just
try to calculate this relation
and the relation of that.
One last piece of the
traces, this gamma
matrices, it's shown here.
Only with four or
more gamma matrices
can you define or
find a non-zero trace
involved in gamma matrices.
And here's one
example where you have
the product of five or four
gamma matrices with gamma 5.
And that's equal in this case--
4 times 3i times the
total asymmetric tensor.
The total asymmetric tensor
is defined as minus 1,
or even for rotation of
those numbers here plus 1
for odd permutations
and if there's
two instances of this state.
All right, again,
I'm not showing you
this in too much detail.
But I encourage
you to play around.
And you will be asked
in the next homework
to play around with some of
the compilations with that.